Deadly Wi-Fi impossible girls great
intelligences here we go the bells of
st. John bully this is a strange beast
this thing partly because it is kicking
off a strange segment of Doctor Who
series 7 is such a weird thing
especially given how cleanly broken in
half it is it's it's a very strange
experience to watch going through
because it really does feel like you're
watching two completely separate series
the first half in the second one does
not really lead into the other not all
that much but let's focus in
specifically on this so we have the
introduction of well technically not we
saw her at the end of the snowman but we
have the proper full introduction of
Clara and her beginning to actually join
and travel with the doctor we have the
return of the great intelligence we have
this whole concept of Wi-Fi that sucks
your soul out we have a lot of weirdness
going on here and there are bits of it
that are interesting and work but it's a
lot piled on top of each other and it
doesn't quite pull together I think
there's a there's a number of reasons
for that I think honestly I think Moffat
was trying to do too much because he was
trying to bring us the new companion
unfortunately so many of the questions
raised about that companion aren't
getting addressed yet and it makes her
introduction feel a little bit off
because she's being brought into things
almost as if it was just any other
companion but it's not and we're not
really dealing with that yet which like
that's weird we are dealing with doctor
coming out of a little bit of a form of
some
retirement ok that's handled decently
enough we are dealing with the return of
the great intelligence and we're dealing
with this very strange idea on Wi-Fi and
I think I get what that last one also
doesn't quite work that's those are sort
of the two main things that don't
they're not the only things going on but
those are the two bits that suffer the
most I think from the layering of
elements is the introduction of Clara
and the spoon heads Wi-Fi Seoul thing
story be and they not it's not that
either of those is an inherently bad
idea maybe what they did with Carr was
inherently bad idea but get back to that
but they both needed more room to
breathe and by a force be I being forced
to share a single episode shared the
time with each other plus all the other
stuff going on in this
yeah they don't quite work and aren't
really properly fleshed out let's let's
kind of start with the with the Wi-Fi
thing I feel like I get where the
initial kernel came from it's not
dissimilar to how a lot of really
interesting Doctor Who stories in the
modern era have been done sort of taking
this thing well how do we take this
thing that people are familiar with and
make it into something scary something
terrifying
they did it with statues with blink they
did it with just darkness and shadows in
silence of the library it was done with
something as basic as basically a bust
breaking down in midnight so that sort
of thing has yielded positive results
before the idea of trying to make Wi-Fi
scary doesn't quite work for a couple of
reasons the first is that the the way in
which it's made scary is a much bigger
leap then I think a lot of the other
stuff has been because you look at
something like blink a statue moves whoa
that's immediate and visceral you look
at silence in the library
human beings are already kind of built
in to be scared of the dark anyway so
that's playing on primal fears existing
fears also similarly with statues
because they statues can trigger the
uncanny Valentinian like it's looks so
close to human but it's not quite or
with midnight you know you're stuck in a
confined space you can't see what's
outside that's a really easy fear to
play off of so all those things play off
the primal fears having your soul sucked
out of your body isn't really a primal
Universal fear so what they decide to
try and have the Wi-Fi do does is
immediately less effective than some of
that other stuff because it's a much
more contrived sort of threat it also
doesn't help how slowly those heads turn
around like the image of the backside
being hollowed out that's actually
pretty creepy it's a decent visual but
for how slowly that thing turns around
my immediate question is always why are
they just standing there staring why
aren't they running away so like the
first time it happens to Clara
okay she's stunned by what she sees
she's just like okay fine
but that happens too again and she just
sits there and then it happens to the
woman and chard who's running the whole
thing and she doesn't she's she just
stays there going no no run like we
don't know enough about how these work
to understand why they can't just run
and so the fact that they don't comes
off as very contrived and very stupid
there's also the thematically linked but
not logistically linked idea of hacking
people and being able to tinker with
them raise and diminish paranoia loyalty
in all obedience all those sorts of
things which is again a very cool idea
and I can't help but flashback to my
thoughts on gridlock and the idea of the
drugs for emotions that that is an idea
that I am annoyed to see sort of tossed
away as a background element in a story
when it easily could have been the
backbone of
something and been much more fully
integrated into a story and instead like
I said it's a background detail it is
somewhat linked in terms of like the
theming of messin with people and toying
with them and all that so like it's not
completely detached it's not as detached
as the emotional drugs were in gridlock
but it does have that same sort of thing
where like this is an interesting enough
idea that should be carrying its own
story that said the final payoff at the
end when when they reset factory
settings which first of all that's a
great just way to put it
it honestly did break my heart when that
when that woman who was running it
collapses and with this very small voice
where is where's my mom and dad they
said they'd be right back oh that hurt
because she did such a good job in both
the vocal delivery and in her expression
in her eyes especially attaining that
sort of wide-eyed I don't understand
what's going on fear that children can
do and as a parent that hit it's it's a
somewhat detached emotional beat I think
it's very effective but it's not really
in service of anything it's just kind of
there I'm not saying that it should have
been dropped but it doesn't it doesn't
feed into any kind of theming that's
going on and it doesn't have any
particular impact it's just a really for
me emotionally affecting moment that
doesn't really mean anything in terms of
the overall story I do like bringing
back the great intelligence it's funny
watching this pretty much immediately
after having seen the snowmen because it
creates a very different experience
because in terms of the show itself
there was a fairly sizable gap of time
between when the Snowman aired and when
this aired but in it so the the result
is when we watched it as it airs it was
oh he's back where as you watch it
straight through without that gap of
time it's like oh well we just did him
so it's kind of funny I'm not actually
gonna complain about that because as
aired it felt a bit more momentous cuz
by by sheer volume of time we hadn't
seen him in a while
but in terms of the last story that
happened we just seen him but that only
happens if you're binging through the
way that I currently am so that was just
sort of an interesting thing for me to
know but Richard II grant is wonderful
as the great intelligence he's a great
fit and also this works for me very much
thematically even more so now that I've
seen because I hadn't at the time that
originally aired even more so now that
I've seen some of the classic stuff with
the great intelligence I've seen web of
fear and so I have a better sense of him
and I feel this all fits and this feels
very consistent for what the great
intelligence is what it is trying to do
so I really do I really do dig this so
coming off all of that let's talk about
the doctor and Clara so Matt Smith gets
he gives actually a really good
performance in this he he is you know
intrigued by her he is infuriated by
what the great intelligence is doing he
has a very clever solution sending the
the spoon head that looks like him to
the shark that's a very cool solution to
the problem very clever it's nice to see
the doctor instead of just techno
babbling his way through that I mean
there's a little bit of that because he
had he had to hack something that they
made so there's a little techno a little
bit of technological wizardry going on
there but his plan is outright clever
and it's nice to have that going on
which you know I I feel like doesn't
always have it as much as I would like
to do but here it's the its present and
I like that a lot but okay so here's the
problems with this introduction of Clara
it works better re watching it now
knowing what Clara is
and who she is and how she's going to
impact the doctors timeline later on but
having something work better once you
already know what it is that's not a
positive especially when you're dealing
with a mystery because the idea to watch
it as it airs is to lure people into the
mystery but the mystery when you don't
know what's going on is very convoluted
because we we are now on our third
iteration of Clara and the thing was
while there were some consistencies in
terms of characterization ie being
clever quick-witted and things like that
there was a different feel to aasman
than there was to governess Clara
so we've already kind of established
that these are these people are somehow
connected but they also don't at least
appear to realize they have any
connection and there do appear to be
differences like the whole aspect of
governess Clara was this whole she's
actually more rough-and-tumble than she
comes across and she kind of hides that
which was not an element at play at all
in Oz when sahn sensation may not have
had that going on but we didn't see it
so we've already been introduced the
idea that they these are distinct
incarnations but then Moffat makes the
mistake of not actually doing a lot of
specific characterization to the version
of Clara we actually get it's like he's
counting on the fact of oh well you
already know Clara you've seen her twice
before but the thing is we don't really
we at the time this aired if you don't
already know what's going on we don't
know enough about it to be able to
safely assume well she's going to behave
like the previous two especially because
there were already differences between
the previous two so Moffat made the
mistake of giving so little time to
directly characterize this companion and
again I think because he was counting us
on us having seen her twice before but
he shouldn't have been counting on that
that because we didn't know how those
connected to her and neither
the doctor now I buy it that the doctor
kind of latches on to her in terms of
like something weirds going on let's
poke it with a stick you know that
mentality that he has I get that but the
problem is that aside from that there
really is no reason given for this
connection to happen and this is
especially frustrating for me because I
look back at something like say the
eleventh hour so much work went into
characterizing Amy and giving us very
tangible believable reasons why Amy
would travel with the doctor Moffett put
it so much work in there that he just
didn't do with Clara and I think that's
kind of what happens when you have I
mean I've made my complaints about
mystery box style storytelling in Doctor
Who before but this is an added layer of
when your mystery box is a person active
character in the story because you one
thing is going to give either it's going
to be a very poorly integrated mystery
because you're focusing on them as a
character or they're not going to be a
properly developed fully integrated and
realized character because you're
focusing on them as a mystery element
and I think Moffat leaned more to that
end of things and it just is it just
makes things frustrating to watch
because he's banking on the idea that we
already know her we don't and this
version of Clara is also already kind of
changing anna is also miss didn't see
here's the thing we have the mystery of
why does this woman keep appearing but
we also may even have a ton of
information about this specific person
even if we set aside the we've seen her
alive and die twice before and just zoom
in on her we learn almost nothing about
Clara we know that she's not good with
computers until she suddenly is because
of the hole down downloading an upgrade
thing that happened to her we know that
she watches after some kids she wants to
travel but has it and that's it we don't
really know how she ticked
we don't know how she works we don't
find out about how she processes the
world the way that we did find that out
about Rose Martha
Donna Amy that's just not granted to us
here and it's a big part of why
right off the bat Clara was a sticking
point for me she just isn't being given
the foundation as a character that every
other companion in the modern era had
gotten up to this point and it just
makes her on initial introduction into
the story proper way more shallow again
I will admit this works better now that
I've seen Clara's entire run and I
understand her as a character I am
actually able to enjoy what has happened
to hear more now but that is that is a
failing of the story because we didn't
get any answers for episodes and I
honestly feel like she wasn't fully
properly characterized and so she had
her time with Capaldi so that's not a it
was good the whole time I just didn't
realize it because I didn't know where I
was going no I consider that a flat-out
failing the character didn't work until
explained if you're going to have a
mystery character you can have the
reveal and the explanation
recontextualize them absolutely but you
still have to build them properly as a
character in their own right in the
first place and this just doesn't and it
just makes things really frustrating
so that's bells of st. John some
interesting ideas undercooked some great
moments some clever moments some which
don't really feel like they properly
connect to everything the introduction
of a companion who I have a lot of
problems with but I think even separate
from my later issues with the character
I just think this introduction is not
very good the only thing that it's got
going for it is the inherent charm of
the actress and she has that and it
helps
but it's not enough not for me I also
personally don't think she had the best
chemistry with Matt Smith especially
compared to what the doctor had with Amy
now I do think her chemistry with
Capaldi was better but I will address
that when we get there cuz yes I'll keep
going through and redoing ones that I
have seen but having rewash in a while
but that'll I have done reviews on
before I mean anyways
that'll wrap up this one have you rewash
this lately what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do down there as well like
subscribe share this around that helps
me out immensely it also helps if you
consider supporting me on patreon in any
amount that is incredibly helpful
plus there's other links besides but you
don't have to do any of it cuz end of
the day folks you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]